some breaking news overnight from the
u.s on abortion laws hillary clinton has
called it an utter disgrace protesters
have taken to the streets outside the
supreme court saying their deepest fears
are coming true the news that's
triggered this backlash a leaked
document that indicates a majority of
u.s supreme court justices plan to
support overturning a historic law that
legalized abortion
i absolutely have to be out here because
this is something that
affects me so personally and
and hurts so much to know that has
might be ripped away from me
the unborn are human and we've been
killing them in mass to the tune of
millions and so
this
i have no words i have no words
well i use correspondent greg milem is
standing by for us this morning hello to
you greg very good morning good evening
where you are um how has this come about
and when will we know what the plan is
well if the final ruling from the
supreme court which we expect in the
next couple of months um is in line with
this draft ruling it will be hugely
significant for the u.s it will
immediately ban abortion in a number of
states others will follow pretty quickly
as well
um it is unprecedented to get any sort
of leak out of the supreme court it's a
very secretive organization um so the
the a leak of a story of this
significance is astonishing really it's
a draft ruling written by samuel alito
who's one of the the more conservative
supreme court justices it was written in
february it could have been amended
since then but inid says that the
supreme court shouldn't just side with
the states who want to restrict or ban
abortion but they should go further and
they should overturn a thing called roe
v wade now that's a ruling from 1973
that guaranteed a constitutional right
to seek an abortion uh the court has
been deliberating on this since uh
december uh they're due to rule in the
next few weeks hugely consequential uh
ruling and the question always be wars
was how far would they go would they
overturn roe v wade because the court is
very conservative um at the moment now
the impact would be that it would ban
that in in 12 states almost immediately
and many more would follow in huge anger
particularly from democrats okay for now
thanks craig